you said it was three reasons why people
come to you the the three types of
people he said
pain fear of death and debili what was
the other one
yeah so either they can't do what they
want to do
they they can't they can't tolerate the
pain you know the pains or they're
for whatever reason they've decided they
want to stay alive it makes sense i mean
it's a good reason to want to stay alive
and maybe see your grandkids grow up and
the kids grow up
but the what what gets people to a level
from your experience 36 years
20 000 plus patients fasting all the way
up to 40 days
uh uh what gets people to the point of
saying
you know what doc i got to tell you i
know those three things you talked about
is that the breaking point where
somebody says i'm willing to change
and figure out a way to drop some of
these soses and
and change my lifestyle is it anything
more than those three things that you
see where somebody just i want to make a
change in my life
um yeah i think sometimes their
experience of people they know or trust
and they see them having had an
experience that's very motivating
um so you know they know somebody that
had problems like they had and then they
they see them go through what appears to
be a relatively
straightforward process you know you
adopt a healthy diet you get enough rest
you do your exercise and the body heals
itself
and if you want to speed it up we do
this this fasting business
you know it's there is no pill potion
powder product there's no
magic these are ancient practices uh
like i said if you you go to the bible
you can
read about fasting you know there's i
think a hundred thousand plus references
to fasting
so this idea of giving the body a chance
to unwind itself isn't exactly a new
concept
and as far as the diet you know what are
we talking about a whole plant food diet
free of
highly processed food products you know
we didn't used to average 150 pounds of
sugar a year per person
you know in in in the world of range and
ancestors
you know sugar wasn't wasn't even
existent in a concentrated form like
that
and and the same thing salt used to be
such a precious commodity that was used
as a means of exchange
you know worth his salary uh you know it
derives from the fact that
you know these highly fractionated food
products used to be rare
not ubiquitous we've gotten clever we've
gotten smart
uh we've got we're post-industrial
revolution and as a consequence we've
changed our environment now we're in
deep trouble
yeah in one of your interviews i think
you said your brother called you and
said i had a heart attack
and and your reaction to it was not the
typical reaction a sibling would have
and maybe
if you can unpack your reaction it'd be
very helpful
well my brother is five years older than
i am so we grew up together
and you know i got involved in this very
young i wanted to be
a better basketball player because my
best friend doug lyle
used to beat me just mercilessly and i
thought well
you know i practiced it didn't do any
good i thought maybe i'd get healthier
and that would give me an edge and i
would crush him
well the problem was it failed because
he adopted the same diet and he still to
this day i'm 61 years old we go out we
play
competitive basketball he still kicks my
rear every time
so complete failure but it got me
interested i started reading and i read
these books and they said
that doctors that used this approach had
the best job in the whole world because
the body
did all the healing and the patient had
to do all the work
and all you had to do as a doctor was
take credit for the good results and i
thought that's the job for me
you know i got interested in it and so
uh
you know started to pursue this anyway
my brother
you know he continued to live more of a
conventional lifestyle
really brilliant guy but you know ate
too much gained weight
got to the point where his knees were
swollen he couldn't play volleyball
anymore
really starting to suffer of course i
would always give him you know a hard
time
and yeah he didn't want to hear about at
one point my sister-in-law his wife
gets ill comes to our facility does the
fast
recovers avoid surgery does great
becomes adopts a health promoting diet
he still won't do it she's having to
make two meals he's making
she's a younger brother i mean i don't
want to listen
a buddy of his he's he's uh at one of at
uh at
uh boeing so he's you know one of his
buddies from boeing
actually unbeknownst to him comes to our
facility recovers his health
quit smoking gets overcomes his blood
pressure gets off the drugs
goes home and starts to tell my brother
you should go to this place true north
it was really helpful
you know that's my brother won't do it
finally i get the call
he's in the hospital he says alan i've
had a heart attack
and i said well you survived it
that's wonderful he goes no no no you
don't understand i had a heart attack i
said i heard you
best thing that could have happened now
you're going to have to start to listen
so the the surgeon is telling him he's
got to have a four-way bypass
and i asked him to talk to the surgeon
the surgeon he asked the surgeon
if i do this won't they eventually plug
up again
and the surgeon explains yeah they will
plug up again but it'll last much longer
than if we just do stents and whatever
anyway long story short he checks
himself out he adopts a health promoting
diet and lifestyle
he loses 50 pounds he avoids the
procedure
he's able to get he's passed his stress
test he's had a great outcome
and now he's you know he's adopted the
diet and lifestyle
took me you know took him having a heart
attack and me 30 years of nagging
but nonetheless uh today he looks
fabulous and he's doing really well it's
been a couple years now he's back
playing volleyball
everything looks good well i mean you
said you're 61 so that means he's 66
yeah yeah i mean to going out to playing
volleyball doing that that's great here
at 66 years old
well especially after he yeah more power
to him
and the reason why i i wanted to bring
up your brother's stories because
of you saying the types of people that
come to you is pain
debilitating debilitating where they
can't do certain things or fear of death
they finally say listen you know i may
want to do something about my life
you